we're how do you reconcile it right like
where do you go okay am i defending
these bad guys or who are alleged bad
guys how do you is it hard to stomach it
and I mean don't get me wrong I have a
cell phone that's made by child slaves
okay I use it every single day and I
[ __ ] love it
I'm no good person we're all part of bad
[ __ ] that is your how do you reconcile
the proximity do you have to it it it's
I found it to be pretty easy there's two
sides to every story
I really have I really have it's not
difficult I found it harder to sleep and
I was when I was a prosecutor and then
when I become a defense attorney why
going that well that's just how I'm
wired I'm wired a little bit differently
just to break this down for people that
are listening or watching right now so
used to be on the other side used to
work for the state trying to convict the
drug now you're working for the alleged
drug dealers and cartel bosses etc or
people doing these type of crime and
you're trying to make sure the state
can't convict them right you said it was
easy sorry you said it was tougher to
sleep when you were trying to convict
the bad guys than trying to get him off
that's just me personally and I'm
definitely in the minority on that but I
you know I saw from the inside and look
there's great work to be done as a
prosecutor and there's some really bad
people that should be in jail and
there's some bad people that I put in
jail or helped put in jail but that
didn't outweigh I think to overreach by
the police and by prosecutors sometimes
in going after people that didn't do
much wrong all I can tell you is that
I've been to Rikers Island I've been to
prisons around New York State and other
states right and one day in prison is
enough to make someone straight I can
promise you that Strait is in not
homosexual or straight isn't like you're
not gonna know it for that it's the
opposite has gonna open you up narrow
you know I've seen people that are think
they're hardened criminals and have done
something which a lot of people would
consider bad and they look like a bad
person and I visit them after they've
spent their first five days on Rikers
and I can tell you right now they'll
never J walk again in New York City or
elsewhere because it's a terrible place
and you don't think it's kind of like
getting a speeding ticket we're like
right afterwards you I'm never speeding
again and then you drive the speed limit
for an hour you're like [ __ ] balls that
doesn't do anything because you just got
let off but that's all I'm saying is
when you go to jail or the threat of
jail is there yeah it's a whole
different ball game and people toss
around these sentences like three years
for this amount of drugs or five years
for having two guns on you you know
whatever it may be and until you go to
those facilities you don't see how bad
they are mean look at us we're all
quarantined we're in these apartments
with TVs no complaining and we're
complaining yeah we're cleaning out of
our ass and it's crazy
and these people are prison they're
doing weird different things out of
their ass none of the amenities that we
have other things are happening it's
crazy so this is a good example they
were all under home confinement right
now and everyone's complaining yeah so
you said so for you the way you
reconcile it was you felt that jail is
so awful that putting anyone there made
you carry a weight that was incredibly
uncomfortable whereas when you're
getting the guys that have been accused
of drug dealing even if you truly
believe deep down that they are you
think that sending them to jail is just
such an awful experience you'd rather
get them off at its padded space level
yes I think jail does nothing to make
anyone better America has 5% of the
world's population and 25% of the
world's prison population yeah exactly
let's go flex the muscles in America so
so that's that's one of the issues but
look even if jail is not in the question
I have a lot of people that allegedly
committed crimes that aren't facing a
jail sentence like I just see the toll
that it takes just getting arrested and
being put through this system there are
significant other leave them there their
jobs fire them their kids hate them they
get divorced
whatever maybe and they have no other
life line and I've seen people at their
lowest probably add you know to more
like being a therapist than a defense
attorney
I'm calling you know calling me in the
middle of the night and they their
world's falling apart right most of what
happened to a lot of people that you
know I represents have never been in
trouble before and they're never going
to be in trouble again and they got
caught up in something and I just seen
that I like to figure out why people
have done certain things and usually
there's a deeper cause down there and I
can justify it